[Music]
gwyneth's montecito mansion neighbors
oprah ellen prince harry and meghan
markle you must be joking in her new
tour for architectural digest it's clear
that the 49 year olds digs are fit for
royalty welcome to our home nestled in
coastal southern california gwyneth's
humble abode draws inspo from thousands
of miles away
this is portuguese tile it's reclaimed
tile from portuguese prints to european
entryways i really wanted the entryway
to feel like its own special room
to french fireplaces such a luxury to be
able to have a wood burning fireplace in
your kitchen gwyneth is even up in the
antsy when it comes to what she calls
the powder room it's got all this hand
done antiqued mirror and hand painted
wallpaper it's got a reclaimed sink it's
got tons of different textures and metal
finishes it's really pretty
i love it it makes me feel very grown up
when i pee in here as for the fixtures
the woman behind the famous vagina
candle has some interesting pieces like
this chandelier and this chandelier
which i can't decide if it looks like a
grasshopper or lily pads or something
that's what i love about it is the
pearls i think they're so beautiful and
unique there's something also a bit star
trek about it but i've grown to really
love it these dangly lights it's like
the jewelry for the living room and this
living room swing i lie in it all the
time i mean i go there and i read or
talk on the phone or whatever meanwhile
gwyneth says this u-shaped couch is a
hot spot for her family which includes
teens apple and moses they definitely
have
a unique life experience so it's just
our job to keep them
as grounded as we can when it comes to
design inspo gwen is just like us i
found on something similar on like
pinterest
and then i was like i think this would
be such a nice way to finish the wall
again i found this i found the
inspiration on on the internet this
beautiful kind of jade bar and yes the
bar is stocked some japanese whiskey is
usually my favorite thing to have what's
also stocked cookware in the kitchen i
try to have good nutrition
i mean i also believe in
vodka and red wine and cheese and stuff
so it's all about the balance being
happy and then there's the holy grail of
the home it's a bit of a spa
moment happening
understatement understatement complete
with a cold plunge pool hot tub and
sauna maybe i can write it off as a
business expense the goop founder who
says she's into wellness so it's
justified puts the spot to good use i
come in here every day i use it all the
time and whenever i'm in here i'm like
pinch me i cannot believe that this is
our house so we live here
you